they fought for their country and now
they're fighting their own personal
battle soldiers wounded on the front
line now facing a long road to recovery
i fully remember how i was hit how i
felt down i couldn't feel my legs and i
saw a lot of blood
this hospital unit in kiev used to treat
stroke victims its purpose expanded when
more broke out this unit normally has 30
beds but because of the war they've had
to increase it to 50. and of those 50 42
are occupied by people who were in the
military and have been injured in the
fighting
vitaly philippov has been here for two
months he volunteered for the army when
more broke out his unit was shelled
shrapnel ripped through him causing
internal and spinal damage he couldn't
walk when he arrived but there are signs
of hope
i will be able to walk again the doctors
are very good here i can feel and move
my legs
maybe in two weeks i will try to walk by
myself
most here are making progress the daily
sessions in the gym help but it's slow
it's painful and not just physically
ladislav shitnik stood to greet me a
huge achievement hit by shrapnel he
thought the damage was permanent
i said to my comrade i've lost my legs
he looked at me and said no you still
have legs it was a huge relief
he knows that when he's released from
hospital
the real challenge begins
rehabilitation will last long after i
leave hospital but i hope in the future
i will feel the same and i can walk and
run like before
igor prokhopovic is the head of
department he's been a doctor for 22
years all his experience in training has
not prepared him for the injuries he's
had to deal with over the last five
months
it was hard in the beginning we were
working 24 hours a day and we learned by
doing now it's easier we have enough
knowledge for the treatment and
rehabilitation
[Music]
these young men will bear the scars of
their injuries long after the war is
over a shadow across an entire
generation
alan fisher aljazeera keeve